gut freunde bitte ich mein zimmer
ich hab mir gedacht schneck ich gestern
kam kein video am schlimmsten metern
brust
ich habe mir gedacht freuen wir gestern
haben wir schon kein minecraft video
weil die akkus saison aber komplett
komisch ist minecraft video weil ich
mich innerhalb von zwei tagen sechs neue
kia ich habe sehr viele neu gemacht
danach ohne mal wieder selbst einkaufen
sind hab ich mir gedacht ich zeige euch
heute im samstagabend video man bei
einer aufnahme ist immer super rande
vermerkt ob meine schnauze voll
später zeige ich euch endlich system von
muskeln dass die jetzt im kleiderschrank
praktisch nicht was der mann suchen er
war von der vermieterin schon da reißen
wir können überhaupt machen das ist
wirklich einfach klamotten klamotten
klamotten und auf der anderen seite
haben wir natürlich auch einfach
klamotten anderen stand haben
das ist einfach leider stand der ist
aber auch nach unten mit drin was wir
hier vorne haben sind so akustikplatten
also schaumstoff ich weiß nicht so
voller menschlich wird die vielleicht
irgendwann anbringen habe ich noch nicht
gemacht hat legt dass wir freuen uns
einfach so eine stange die kann ich
nehmen und dann ging ich habe relativ
viele dachfenster dann kann ich einfach
so da und schauen ins ausland da jetzt
hier sind so zwei sportler warum ich mir
die geflitzt verrät ganz prägen fünf
stück wand dabei design maria winkler so
viele davon haben wir machen wie ich
habe stifter hier beispielsweise mit am
start dann habe ich hier sei die sticker
ganzen und es geht bisschen runter bis
keine ahnung hier kommt die 4 so
erscheint das habe ich hier gegen die
sonnenstadt break vorne
es ist also quasi mein verstaut schrank
für alles irgendwie hier wirklich genial
was machen akustik hochzeit sind das die
lache die nehme ich dann mal mittel
rüber wenn ich aufnehmen will ich die
lampe hier 15 euro amazon also high
quality hier auf einem cello die stelle
ich dann auf jeden fall hier hin und
schließlich dann einfach kann liegt hier
an der steckdose mariano damit ziemlich
genau dort setzt einfach ich setze mich
an jedem fall gebracht
und meine videos auf bevor wir dann zum
setup und so kommt es bei ihr diese ecke
doch und zwar hier ist ein ganz normaler
tina müller es ist nicht clean
wir schauen was drin ihr haben wir dann
noch ein paar sachen drin video
beispielsweise das kissen für den stuhl
hier haben wir ein paar uni sachen bwl
da treffen zwei der kamera equipment
andere kamera und jede kamera stand da
unten liegt man noch so ein paar
unterlagen für die uni also die tri
leister sachen und noch mal so ein paar
komische hab deine wo nix drin steht das
ist mein stuhl auf dem ich mal sitze das
ist ein dx racer keine ahnung finde ich
nicht so krass bequem wird sich an den
rand setzen aber kein fan also kann ich
euch nicht empfehlen hier ist meine
christ haben sec in bezug auf youtube
ich habe mir das kotzen was am 17 06 in
denen die kabine
da kommt davon sechsten rein es ist
ultra flauschig und spaß ist wirklich
fertig ist richtig fleisch ich mein
bestes richtig fleisch es ist richtig
fleißig thema wir haben wir einem stativ
ich habe hier auf balou stehen wie
techno und halt dieses porsche roboter
ding was ich mir für vr sachen benutzer
da ich mein drucker funktioniert zwar
noch bilder vom new yorker aufgabe
wir haben voll auf wachstum wurde den
ganzen rest einer wohnung in new york
wurde schädel stern nicht gar nicht so
toll endlich das ist quasi eine wand wo
alles dran was vormachen muss also eine
pizza einkaufen weil luca video shopping
de und schippert das ips steht auch oft
oder stinkt so häufig datensätzen wollte
mal hin auf meinen stuhl und zwar mit
ihren teppich läufer wohl aber damit ein
bisschen bequemer sitzen
und ja ich hab ein imac dass ihr schon
ich habe aber gerade windows drauf weil
ich auf meine gegen videos aufnehmen
doch ein weg das ganze ist apple das
ganze schneide weil ich hasse wird doch
die liebe apple und das ist quasi zum
ein riesiger garten instagram bekommen
youtube.com ich hab hier bei den
aufnahmen equipment steht auch alles
beschreiben dass ich hab wirklich nur
dieses micro hat dann eben schnell rüber
klappe und dann geht das kabel daran und
das da rein und dann läuft hat alles als
ich jetzt nicht zehn millionen interface
oder sowie die fällige trotzdem
irgendwie klar wenn dich mein magen
knurrt so heftig wie ein gewitter man
freunde dann ja wie gesagt ich hab ja
auch eine windows tastatur aber in
wegen seiner mama von vor zehn jahren
also usb hub von 10,84 eine lampe milch
ikea qualität die hitze können sich
einfach wirklich nur dazu da um karte
besitzen den blick davon wegnehmen uns
ein bisschen entspannter das nicht zu
machen wenn ich mal kein richterin habe
auch ikea die lampen aruba liegt sonst
noch was zu zeigen was habe ich denn
hier eigentlich drin hier in sinnlose
sachen da ist irgendwas von verpackung
und neuen verpackungen und eps
verpackungen alle der ganze städte ich
mag den gp mal wieder rein also da
verstehe ich auch immer nur alles drin
bin ich gerade mitten in kanal kommen
und hier unten sieht so ein paar
karnevalskostüme feuer so ein scheiß
also das war es auch wirklich einfach
schon
ich glaub mir erst gar nicht zeigen sind
normale schlichte weiße wände darf ich
will zwei nägel reingehen weil ich
dachte ich hänge dann entwendeten in der
dann nicht gehalten
ein trauriger moment ganz schlechten
boden also es ist jetzt es ist sehr sehr
kleines aufnahme zimmer dadurch direkt
gesagt sagen die sache deswegen mich so
viele gefragt hatten wer mich gefragt lu
karossen dein schreibtisch weil hier
durchgezogen das holz sondern hier dran
freunde um das geheimnis lüften das sind
zwei ikea platten das sind einfach das
hier ist eine nun unbedingt zu
beschränken dass wir falls ein begriff
und das ist wirklich einfach nur ikea
platten dass wir einen draufgelegt und
hier und hier von übel und rotoren das
jetzt klingelt ist es wirklich einfach
das kann man theoretisch mit viel kraft
jetzt hier abziehen des kanals
draufkleben ich liebe es einfach über
eck zu arbeiten wenn die zuseher okay
ich meine sachen liegen hier habe ich
alles gesehen steht vom tisch das ist
keine sammeln fertigung und das war
einfach lutz idee das zu schaffen freude
dann würde ich sagen hier mit blick auf
das video heimlich nachts es geht
tatsächlich länger arbeitet man auch
nicht wirklich nicht viel vorhanden
es ist jetzt nicht so wie berliner oder
so dass dann noch 10.000 kameras und was
letztlich für luxusgüter warum stehen
habe das ist wirklich einfach ne scheiß
pc nimmt abstellraum mit meinem
kleiderschrank im hintergrund also sorry
falls sie da etwas großes erwartet habe
die haben sicher auch eine komplette
wohnung gewünscht so ein mensch bin ich
allerdings nicht das ist mir ein
bisschen zu privat weiß tatsächlich
einen preis geben
und ich habe allein schon beim ton
anderer leute auf richtig gesehen dass
die ich diese wohnung ebenfalls bei
immobilienscout damals gesehen haben und
daher wusste wo sie wohnen so das ist
ein bisschen kritischer kopf in der tat
jetzt wegen wir erst mal so eine kleine
ist mein aufnahme zimmer mäßig hoffe es
hat euch gefallen hat das getan hat
freut sich über eine wertung gelang
nicht denn auch an entfalten kommt wenn
nicht fündig werden
springer mal die freunde was haltet ihr
von der neuen kamera praktisch ist und
der kiefer nicht an so nah ran so
gefallen hat
schreiben sie kommentare wollte mehr vom
rationalen mir dran für abhängig von dem
zimmer hier schon mal also das ist
wirklich lecker freut wieder den ganzen
tag wirklich weh aber ich habe jetzt ab
befolgt wieder per video kommt mein auto
bis zum 1